Yo, what’s good, kids? Welcome back
to Thug Notes.
Today, we reppin the one percent with "The Great Gatsby" by F. Scott Fitzgerald.
Now, Nick Carraway is an Ivy League white-boy who rents a house in Long Island,
next door to the pimpin crib of Jay Gatsby, a rich playboy with dat mad Mitt Romney money.
Across the way, my boy, Nick, be chillin with his cousin Daisy and her man, Tom.
Now, what Daisy don’t know is that Tom got hisself a sexy ho on the side named Myrtle.
Now, Myrtle is married to some weak-ass punk named George who can’t please his woman.
One day, while kickin it at Gatsby’s crib, Nick discovers that his cousin Daisy used to be Gatsby’s main bitch.
He moved to Long Island in hopes that he might get a crack at that ass again.
Anyway, all these rich white folks
decide to take a trip to Manhattan together.
These fools arrive at the Plaza Hotel, where Daisy’s hubby, Tom, gets all crunk about Daisy and Gatsby’s relationship.
Gatsby and Tom get all up in each others’ grills and tell Daisy that she’s got to choose her man.
But, this bitch can’t make up her mind!
Back in the hood, George straight up says “Myrtle, I know you been actin like a dirty skank.”
Myrtle loses her shit with George and says “I wouldn’t have to play you if you didn’t act like such a bitch.”
So, Daisy be driving Gatsby’s car back
to Long Island when dat crazy hoe
Myrtle just goes up and slings her
ass in front of the car. Bam! She dead.
Daisy just keeps drivin
Gatsby’s whip, gets the hell out of
dodge, and decides she’s done with
Gtasby.
When Tom finds our about the
murder, he goes up and tells George
that it was Gatsby who was driving
the car.
Now George
be thinking that it was Gatsby who
was Myrtle’s stud. So that boy
George grabs himself a 9 and caps
Gatsby while he chillin in his
pool. Then he dun ice himself. Damn.
After dealing with all this rich
white boy angsty bulls***, Nick
decides he needs to get his ass
out of New York and chill out in the
mid west.
Let’s get right to it, homeboy.
“Gatsby” can be considered a
criticism of the anti-Calvinistic
image of the American dream.
America may have started as a land
where homies always got each others
backs, But Fitzgerald’s America is
full of back stabbin crackers that
make Gatsby’s romantic dream
ridiculous. My boy Gatsby keeps it
real by stickin to his American
ideals.
Like dat fool Minter
says “ Because of the beauty of his
dream and the heroism of his
efforts to move beyond it, Gatsby
can be made great”
Check this motif son,: dreams vs.
Reality. Gatsby has these big ass
delusions about the future with this
bitch, Daisy.
Gatsby be thinkin’
that you can repeat the past but my
brother be straight trippin. Cuz on
the real, ain’t nobody can recover
past time.
You can see that Fitzgerald embodies this motif in
tiny details. For example, on page
50 it’s revealed that Gatsby has a
big ass stack of books, most of
which he’s never read. It’s like
Gatsby be frontin’ trying to look
all intelligent and shit. But dat
ain’t reality, B.
Yo, you ain’t know shit about
Gatsby til you know about the
symbol of the green light. Some
playas think the green light
symbolizes the fading optimism of
Gatsby’s dream. At the beginning of
the book, the green light has a
burning quality that gets Gatsby
all riled up about shackin up with
his bitch. But by the end of this
book, it’s just another lame ass
green light. There ain’t nothing
special bout it, just like his fake
ass dreams.
Yo thanks for tuning in to Thug
Notes. I hope yo bitch ass learned
something today. See you next time
playa.